hello everyone and welcome to part four
of my resident evil village playthrough
um i've turned hdr off
which means the game looks less red but
um
for everyone asking me to turn the
brightness up just to show you
it is the brightest it can possibly be
uh
it asks me to adjust until the square is
barely visible
but at no point can i ever see the
square this is sort of the same
there's no blue or red here there was
before now we just have everything as
bright as possible
it doesn't look like it's going to get
any better but if anyone finds any
like useful articles or anything please
let me know because this game is
is look at at least i can see a little
bit more now it's not as dark
in any case oh that's exciting
i don't need the network um is the game
haunted
we just sort of went underneath the
castle
um and i did get my map and i really
haven't been clearing out the areas
because i'm just assuming that i'm gonna
have to go back to the main hall at some
point right so
everything's still very red or
unexplored oh we're going to the ladies
chambers
oh my
but based on having taken out cassandra
i think i probably do need to start
trying to make sure i collect everything
like that was that what was in the
stream it was all right
you're just going to save again just for
good measure okay
good stuff all right okay
this does look a lot better but it's
still pretty [ __ ] dark
you're going to fall
hello i just feel like
if i stood up i'd be at a good height
you know i'm just gonna
[Music]
offer that tidbit there's no way she
can't see me there is no way you cannot
see me mother miranda
i regret to inform you that ethan
winters has
escaped that fool heisenberg
because he is in my castle and has
already proven too much for my daughters
to handle
when i find him yes
no mother miranda yes
of course i understand the importance of
the ceremony
i won't let you down hmm
throw me like that mirror to hell with
the ceremony
that man will pay for what he's done
what do you like what's what are you
like planning to do about it though like
what
how in what way am i gonna
wha how would you would you like me to
pay
okay cool i'm just not scared of her
that's the problem
i'm not scared about oh okay
beautiful
i'm sure that'll change though
i'm pretty it it'll change surely it'll
change she's going to chase me at some
point and then she's going to become a
tentacle monster i'm just sure of it we
were all called by mother miranda to
decide the fate of the child's father it
me
just thinking of that family meeting
makes me shudder to think i'm treated
like assisted those miscreants
especially heisenberg that riffraff
wouldn't know proper matters if they
slapped him in the face
i would have sliced him to ribbons if
mother hadn't stopped me
why does she treat me the same as them
she gave me this castle obedient
daughters everlasting life did she not
am i not a favorite am i not special oh
mommy issues often unexplored in the neo
games
and it's interesting that the internet's
mommy has money issues
uh oh
um it does make sense that rose would
have been in there
um this isn't gonna open of course not
excuse i'll find use for that family
photo somewhere damn you
it's probably gonna be when mia shows up
also as a technical monitor
even though she was shot a hundred times
oh there's a key here hold up what where
was that
where are you telling me there's a key
did i just did i just [ __ ] that up did i
just throw it outside wow is that key
oh there it is okay great
see what i mean about the standing
height you know is um
i just
you know i think we try to go through
here or do we just
i think she went that way so maybe we
just go this way
oh god
you ungrateful selfish wretch
you come into my house you lay your
filthy man-hands on my
daughters and now you even try to steal
my property
rest while you can because i will
hunt you and i will break you
yeah do it do it queen come come bring
me
she did scare me when she came through
the door window okay i'll give her that
that was pretty spooky
but now she's gonna be like a mr x i
guess
we have to go that way i'm just gonna
keep looking around first
cool got everything in here okay
this is what i was expecting to happen
um i've not had it spoiled for me
conveniently but this is what i was
expecting so i think this is gonna be my
lost ant
probably in the castle
let's go it's gonna be it's gonna be
like jack
like mr x she's gonna just show up
and i am very scared um of uh
jumpscare's video games i'm not gonna
pretend that me saying oh this isn't
even that scary
doesn't mean that i'm not gonna still
scream at something popping out at me
okay just to be just to be clear i'm a
big scaredy cat
all right
anything anything
that i can see which seems suspicious
nothing to loot in here at all
damn
alrighty
i don't know
ethan's hands dude wow
oh that's a that's it oh that's that's
oh no oh no i thought that was a dead
end no that's not bad i thought it was a
dead end i i was wrong it wasn't a dead
end i made a mistake you can't do that
that's super rude
that is a difference
oh [ __ ] off dude you're too tall you're
too tall and too fast
no i [ __ ] that up i [ __ ] that up
that was my fault i deserved that one
we'll take that out and take that that's
my bat
okay
try again okay
so i have to make sure i'm oriented
correctly
that's where she throws me to this is
where the exit is so i just gotta loop
around her i think probably
i have to watch the hand thing again
buddy oh my
god
truthfully i think the kid sucks i don't
think that we need to have all this
hubbub
you will learn what it means
okay um
[ __ ] okay cool this way
and then i gotta open it my own hand
oh i get to keep it well that's a huge
win where is she where is she where is
she where is she where she
i don't know where she is oh no
oh my okay
hello
cool let's go
i know there's something else me to loot
in here [ __ ] [ __ ] dick
cool how did she get through did she
open something
okay great okay cool okay great okay
cool cool
cool cool sweet sweet sweet sweet sweet
sweet
i think i'm just gonna have to take the
l on whatever it was that i was trying
to
get there
great i love that for me i missed
something probably
well i'm not running though i'm on an
elevator do you think that that will
work in my favor
yeah now that'll fix it and then you
just put the hand back on and then
you'll
yeah you got it dude you're fine you'll
be just
fine it's good fluid very good fluid
oh this is back in that opening area
well the the little courtyard it even uh
fixed his jacket
my god
okay let's see there's a lot of [ __ ]
that i have not checked out
appropriately
that again i don't know what kind of
track she's on
do you know what i'm saying
i feel like this area is going to be
okay what the [ __ ] was that oh hello
is that it no um maybe this area is not
going to be okay because
oh oh great okay wonderful
well
i didn't i didn't expect this i didn't
expect friends to show up here oh
[ __ ] i really need to just wait for it
to close i already know that wait for
the
wait for the red don't get too excited
okay
nothing oh my god this why do they sound
like they're right next to me
where are you oh my god that's chilling
not now mate not now
okay i'll take that i'm just trying to
find loot man all right they're just
gonna grow out of the ground though
aren't they
[Music]
sure okay oh my god
oh my god
maybe i should run maybe i should run
are you thinking maybe running is what i
should be doing
rather than wasting ammo i'm just trying
to loot dude
is that it [ __ ] i don't really
i'm not trying to hang out with y'all
you know i'm not out here trying to make
friends
[ __ ] it is still very dark
i think that maybe i should just call it
you know maybe i don't need
every single coin
in this establishment unless it's
something to do with statute potentially
i don't think i want to kill you
i don't think i don't think i want to
oh well
not quite what i was going for i'm going
to check out the statue in the middle to
see if there's an item
or something attached to it i'm gonna
avoid
you where is he oh can't blue
[ __ ] how do i keep losing everything
nothing
no you don't why'd the camp fluid go
to be clear i am playing through obs um
which means the screen is quite small
and my own webcam is covering parts of
it uh this is not the normal way to
be playing a video game under any
circumstances
they do drop stuff that is true i do
want their drops
would have thought i had you on that one
oh that was a good dodge you can even me
to do it
all right we can craft
we are doing okay yes
yes oh i can stack those
there's still more [ __ ] out here it's
got to be
hey how long you all going to spawn for
all right that's my [ __ ] question
there's that okay still no damn it
i just don't think it'll bring me back
out here but maybe it will
i don't think this is worth it i don't
think this is worth it
i think i should let him go
[Music]
they're gonna spawn forever so i'm gonna
go through the lady d
dole i think okay
great key very useful
is she really [ __ ] up by letting me
get it okay what is this
oh yes she lives upstairs-ish
okay
oh unless i could actually get to the
top of the opera hole
maybe
hmm
hmm
what's gonna keep breaking windows maybe
she won't like it
oh okay
it sounds like there's zombies inside
the house now is what that sounds like
quite aggressive sound design oh my god
there sure
are oh my god
the surround sound and these headphones
is too aggressive for me to tell which
direction they're coming from
is a problem that i'm having
okay somebody else is [ __ ] showing up
for sure
oh this [ __ ] up here that i don't have
where are you coming from where are you
coming from
oh my god
it's gonna scare me every time
okay cool what's up in here anything
surely flower swords
oh that's gonna go in the yeah okay cool
i'm gonna break this again
really just because okay is that it
no
just take a little look around i thought
i saw something on the ceiling
do a glint what does that mean
shoot it
interesting huh
who put that there i wonder okay
one day since treatment the string girls
have stopped moving they almost seemed
dead an insect flew out of the eldest
mouse it appears to be a common fly
three bodies are covered in flies it
appears the flies are consuming their
flesh
hot when i open the window some of the
flies drop dead to the floor
oh it's the cold that gets them
interesting um
all three bodies have almost been
completely consumed by the insects all
that's left is a dark riding
human-shaped massive creatures
cute
well i suppose that explains that then
all right downstairs
is that huh well surely she's not that
stealthy
she couldn't be that's she's huge she
could possibly be that quiet
well she would have heard that ethan
very large lady well
okay cool i've not been in here before
oh it's gonna be a piano puzzle
i don't know how to do that
um i keep trying to center them and
failing
similar body structure to blow flies
although there are differences in the
head
it's going to tell me how to kill the
flies carnivorous and vigorously consume
meat
correct they gather using pheromones to
mimic a human
they are produced when a kettle lays
eggs in its house but the flies
themselves are unable to reproduce
they reach sudden drops in temperature
interesting cool who was uh who was
studying all this i
who wonder doing these studies oh thanks
to whoever left that they really
appreciate that
all right not yet not yet we're just we
can keep looking around okay we're not
we don't need to leave in a hubbub
immediately you know
um all right i wonder how i'm supposed
to do this
if i don't know how to read
[Music]
okay it's gonna be about there that's
gonna be there
it sounds beautiful even though i'm not
actually playing anything
let's just back up there that one is
higher
and that one's the same look at me go of
course i did that
who are you kidding
i actually can play a little bit of
piano but i can't read um
sheet music oh we did it cool
okay so
i'm probably gonna go
through here
[ __ ]
uh we've done a circle we have
this is just a circle but now i can get
like back out to the courtyard and then
maybe we go there or go through the
dining room
probably go to the dining room we're
trying to get to the main hall
so that's what we're gonna do which is
this way
thank you hello nobody mind me
don't worry about it i'm just gonna
break all your gloss just in case it
helps but i don't know that she's
she probably actually isn't concerned
about the cold it's just the daughters
just in case all right gunpowder
[ __ ] what's that oh [ __ ] made that noise
somebody just breathe at me play with me
some more
no i'm good i'm good actually i i would
prefer not to i think actually unless i
can
get you to come in here maybe
hang on what if i get you in here in
front of the
window is that gonna help me metal
there's no breeze though
all right love well it's nice seeing you
yeah
just gotta go just straight through
straight to the floor
she's gone what's this
oh i broke that okay that's fine
it's oddly calm
um i think i got the tufa
the moscow sweet i need to find three
more of those
what in the [ __ ] there's so many noises
happening
um we're gonna go see our mate in here
actually
hey bud hello pleasure
not great lost my arm again
well you'll find your way to where once
you're out of this castle
do you have need of anything for the
road ahead
yeah probably but let me deal with this
you're a consistent patronage i've exp
give me a second you [ __ ] salesman
you
it's got to be this right branded my
services
oh oh this is cool i didn't expect that
um probably this way then
okay keep going
must be busy yeah i am
get off my dick push it this way and
then
get it to go uh i can't enter through
there okay push it further
and then just come down through here
nope come on buddy oh does it have to go
through one of them like it's mini golf
surely i can just get it in
fallen okay
what did it do
crimson skull hell yeah it's cool as
hell all right
sweet great
thank you sir we're gonna sell
this one for now
yes and then take a look
that is a very useful thing to have in a
resident evil game i just don't feel
like i need it yet
like hang on if i look at my inventory
i'm like i'm fine so far
i think i want to continue to upgrade my
weapons so let's
we can afford a little bit it's pretty
expensive
why not do the most expensive one first
i guess
no i'm gonna do ammo capacity because
that's the reason i'm not using it
so let's do that uh we can do both we
could do both
and then just run on the assumption that
pretty soon i'm gonna want that
but i don't seem to be having troubles
with money i did also want that though
and that it's all right
i'll be okay i think um is there
anything else i want to sell
i think it's all that i gotta remember
that i have that pipe on the fire though
if you find anything else
hey thanks man i appreciate that i'm
just gonna save for now we're just gonna
hit
save and then we're gonna
keep [ __ ]
looking i guess
i haven't seen her in a while which is
suspicious
so many things to get you know
jeez okay well
oh oh that's good to know
that's the exact one that i thought that
i saw something it won't last until
really i love a girl he doesn't last
long it's actually very helpful for me
i wish i had women chase me
with this much enthusiasm at any point
in my life
you know okay
hello hot daughter are you around here
somewhere
or have you departed the immediate
vicinity
i can't see her no she's here
she's [ __ ] here all right i hear you
just [ __ ] off
i'm just trying to find have you seen
any masks woman
why is mother getting involved why
do we decide that was necessary oh this
might open now is this gonna be the iron
iron one or whatever there was another
door somewhere that i couldn't open yet
um maybe it's downstairs leave me alone
damn it
i
thank you i did think it was really mean
when she called me stale i thought that
was
excessively harsh um
no no
[Music]
i've not been to the hall of joy at all
okay we could do that or the whole
oh that's where they're going to be oh i
wish i had a look at this earlier okay
so we've got the one in the hall of
them i need the hole of joy the whole
pleasure
was an armory what's up what's up with
that
okay let's go back out
and then go to the hole i can't get into
the hole of joy
i can't through the opera hole is that
what you tell me
okay i'll go back outside okay got it
yeah yeah yeah i know i know it
all right all right all right all right
okay so go back to the opponent
trying to fight these whoa what oh
hello okay i just didn't i didn't expect
you to be here
hello nice to see you again i really
missed you um i just didn't think that
you'd be here
right now so color is all surprised
um can i open this now maybe with that
other key
great okay cool let's roll
really no
just like give me a second hang on i
need to like heal again
all right okay oh great
i could maybe kill her where'd she go
where is she
see you hey you are you stupid [ __ ]
that's the plan maybe i can just shoot
him
shotgun
did she close it oh she did i see i see
i see i see
where are you woman
this does this seems like it's going
okay oh that hurt a bit but you know
ethan's had a worse
had much worse experiences we're being
honest
no no no no no we're just gonna do that
again okay we're just gonna keep doing
it
that's gonna keep sucking for you
it's so cold
[Music]
that's a shame didn't find her on that
one it's okay it's
literally right there and then we'll
just [ __ ] hit her again
i do not no you think you're super cute
but that doesn't mean i love you
is that it good good
surely that's it and then she'll stay
even though it's closed again
right right right right right yeah boom
and then i think we try to combine
[Music]
hmm
didn't mean to do that that was an
accident okay uh
we can figure that out the shot okay
so what's going on in here can we get to
the hole of joy
because that's probably where the next
thing is going to be right in here
i don't feel like this is going to be
remarkably easy
but i guess we'll find out
shall we nothing nope okay
just out here committing knife crimes to
satisfy my curiosity
okay i don't think this is gonna go well
for me
i don't think any of this is gonna
no
hmm well
that
no okay we're just we're just gonna try
it we're just gonna give it a shot
did not explode
okay suspicious
oh oh this is cool oh
oh my oh interesting okay
let the five bells of this chamber ring
out
will do noted is that her
she's hot i don't know if you guys knew
that but she is
quite attractive and i will take the
handgun ammo
thank you cool a tortoise
it's a lot more detail oh
um in this game now that i can see it
slightly better
and i appreciate that babe
he really is passive aggressive you
can't he can't kill them
very easily so he's just you know got to
do the next best thing
um okay where are the other bells then
that's this is all this is where this
goes just right here
interesting okay well we got one
is it in this chamber as in like in this
exact room
or or not
okay let's we'll shoot that when it
comes back up just see if that's the
right thing to do
okay it was and that's two
where are the other bells is the
staircase here to give me multiple
angles of this mechanism
mayhaps it's not just the same one
more bells can we do anything with this
bells oh that's about
three huh
is that a bell on there
oh it is okay
oh and it's there okay great
cool
okay what's it gonna do
what is happening
oh this is cool
oh yeah yes i will thank you
okay
huh
that was very aggressive i almost
thought that was a jump scare but it was
just him climbing a ladder sorry ethan
thank you for your help
hmm
what am i in an attic or something now
yep pretty literally
all right all of it
i feel like the chances of her being up
here are pretty slim
um a lot of books they a very
reading friendly family you'd love to
see it you know
really
you're not gonna do we really think that
this was necessary today
oh i really thought that was three
headshots
that okay all right stay down oh
there's another lockpick but i have two
more
locked areas that i know of two more
drawers that need uh
oh cool
all right
i heard there was something called the
dagger of death flowers somewhere inside
this castle it's apparently antique from
middle ages it's coated in a concussion
of poisons from across the continent
it's said to have been crafted to kill
demons and monsters
hmm that's how we kill lady d
we poison her
okay
oh yes i think i will
that's why i needed the [ __ ]
inventory space
[ __ ] i can make this work okay i can i
can organize this
hell yeah dude all right
what am i gonna do with it though
and how do i i don't have it equipped to
anything
don't know oh there's something else in
here i'm gonna get okay
it wasn't the goat
okay that's gonna be it all right okay
we got everything
let's roll so i could
not well we're in a room for [ __ ]
anything though so that's fine
all right out of here
oh well that's
new and exciting fun for the whole
family this castle is dope though
this is it's
should you shoot this bird
because that's what i want to key
well
i don't love this one
[Music]
i don't
the yeah are sort of [ __ ]
if i'm being honest it's a [ __ ]
vibe okay
you're gonna make me fight
[Music]
okay buddy okay hey well i'm not used to
your animation yet you're very sporadic
but you're not any harder to kill than
the ground guys
okay all right
okay we can
we'll be all right we can do this things
are much scarier when you don't know how
they function
that is actually what i want here
let's bring out the sniper shall we
this could be fun
i [ __ ] get you i think i missed
i think i missed i think that that i did
i thought i did that and it didn't work
[Music]
i think i might have missed twice so um
i'm not positive that i'm missing though
so maybe just not yet alana maybe one
step at a time
[ __ ] this is huge this area is massive
jesus
well i got him on that one and on that
one
he's probably dead
yep all right cool proceeding as though
he is dead
anything around here that i can grab
okay
all right you nearby got your foot
got your shin i think are you down
is he down is he dead he's not how about
now
no
oh did you try to jump on me bro
personal space boundaries i can't just
probably jumping on strangers yeah i
think that i may have hit them
my hands are really sweaty too from the
sniper bit i was so nervous i was going
to waste bullets i think i made myself
waste bullets um
but maybe maybe i did hit them and they
just take more than one shot to go down
oh these guys are actually not too
difficult to just knife
oh oh my
okay well i don't love that animation
even if it's not
too difficult all right how about now
stay down stay now
that's it for you that's it for you when
you're weird tongue mouth
uh so there's nowhere for me to go here
is what you're telling me
oh i can go
god up it this is so big this [ __ ]
this whole area is so big
okay brilliant even brilliant
great we will take the lay
anything no all right where are you
where are you worried
this directional audio is really not
working
oh no i don't like it it's not i'm not a
fan of it it's pretty it's pretty [ __ ]
up dude that's that's just
assault at this point you need to
[ __ ] chill out where's the other
where is it where is it where
are you up where are you here hey buddy
hello
i see you i see you
oh did i miss every single one of those
shots
jesus come on
all right
wonderful um
no i think we probably need to explore
this better right
we'll just look around a little bit more
surely that's not everything
i can't imagine so
this music is killing me though it's not
ideal
very grating
like we get it you think you're eerie i
understand
the vibes are very obvious
so i could take that elevator
this is these breakable
no um
that's where i came from okay
[Applause]
no you don't know you don't get away
from me
[ __ ] [ __ ]
okay uh maybe that is it
that's all i can do here except for
interact with the elevator which
oh and that okay which we will do
how how do i suppose i get to that
i don't think it's anything to get to um
i'm gonna go for this get
him i'm gonna go staircase and i'm gonna
come back
if i need to we'll see all right what's
going on up here
[Music]
or is it just
interesting just another sort of peek to
the area
hmm i can break all of you
thank you yes love all of this for me
suspicious amount of handgun ammo but
i'll take it
all right
cool fun time
oh oh okay i didn't even realize this
was here
perfect is that everything here that's
everything i needed from this particular
section of this
um there is a ladder
oh it goes down got it okay cool there's
still something i haven't gotten up here
i'm just gonna leave it sorry mate all
right let's go
back down
how many do i have my inventory right
now
two okay
i feel like she's going to show up
pretty quick
just seems like that was probably a bit
loud
just the vibe just feels like that would
have been audible
but maybe i'm wrong
where am i i'm in the entrance hole
i'm in here in ages look i didn't even
know you could break pots the last time
i was here
it's been so long oh
that would have given me sniper rifle
ammo even back then or does it randomize
i don't know
um well it looks like the [ __ ] that i
haven't gotten in both of these rooms oh
that's right
i also didn't know you could break these
so that's that something in here though
oh i keep missing like these glints on
ceilings
okay what's it gonna be did i miss that
there oh it fell
so they just have crystal fragments just
chilling and pausing this house
okay oh um
well no probably not because
i don't actually know where to go if
you're right there if i'm being
perfectly honest
yeah what do you do about that elevator
[Laughter]
she she'd be way over the weight limit
she's 600 pounds
have you seen how old this thing is
there's no way there's no way
okay well back up here again i guess
[Laughter]
oh
well that'll be the thing i couldn't
find it's [ __ ] not god damn it
oh my god
listen i'm here so we're just gonna find
whatever it is that's missing and i
think it's gonna be another one of those
crystal fragments
which i suspect i'm probably missing a
lot of which just means i have to look
out for a glint
somewhere and i'm gonna guess
oh great cool
i think that works did it drop
did it drop did it drop did it drop aha
oh no can i not get to it
okay we got it and that's gonna be it
okay great
those uh if i hadn't just found one of
those by chance
that that yup i feel like a lot of
people are gonna be missing this
um okay let's go back down
okay okay okay okay and then i think
maybe i'll have enough money to buy the
inventory upgrade
potentially which i still don't like
super urgently need
but i will pretty soon i think
so let's do that
why does it sound like she's still here
oh my god she's like
still right here then really
like are you sure she's still here
like but like are we certain
it
[ __ ] sounds like she is but
am i am i being tricked
it sounds like she's getting close up
but i can't see her
okay she's
could she be out the front maybe maybe
she's
in the carriage gate and i just can't
get there you know maybe that's where
she is maybe
you know and door's locked and she can't
get to me either
which is a shame i
just gotta [ __ ] go for it
you know just keep running go straight
to the merchant's room
but break this while we're at it and
then keep going
hello love hello no i won't
i will not learn anything thank you good
day
safe room take a look
i think it's a safe room
okay three of these
one of these and one of these yeah
somebody said something about combining
them can't see the way no way to do it
maybe i'll figure it out later i don't
know right now we're just going to sell
them
and we're going to do that yes
and then i think we'll do one of these
me thank you sir um we don't need to do
that yet
and how's my inventory looking this is a
mess this is an awful looking inventory
let's just you know just get things a
little bit tidier up in here
put the pipe bomb i don't know [ __ ]
yeah here seems fine for these
that's i'm not happy with that but you
know
just because i don't have any
so let's just buy some for that
what else you got here why not make
mines sniper
ammo let's do that yes
all right have a wonderful adventure
thank you sir
i appreciate that um we're gonna save
and we're gonna leave this part here
obviously when i come back
we will be putting the next two masks
in their slots and i think i probably
will try to make sure i clear every room
in the castle
before we put the last one in and see
what happens i'm very excited i will see
you guys then